votar é estou aqui hoje para falar eu
acho que é fácil falar de uma grande
paixão falar do mar pra mim e falar de
algo que está dentro de mim e eu comecei
no mar foi uma paixão que foi
desenvolvendo
depois passou para a montanha e fui
subindo e chegou a não sou piloto nosso
piloto só uma coisa que chama um pinguim
tem nazismo pequena eu não consigo
vários então tem que andar a pendura na
pendura daqueles que sabem voar e que
são e que são pilotos mas eu estou aqui
hoje para tentar com vocês e precisa da
nossa ajuda todos vocês para falarmos um
carinho de o que é que nos faz mover
como é que nós conseguimos nessa
sociedade é enquanto somos crianças
transformar em tudo aquilo que queremos
fazer em concretizar em chegar ao ponto
final em chegar aquilo que nós
respectivamente que seria o nosso futuro
vamos contar uma história é minha
história e portanto é perdoem me se eu
muitas vezes o fizer essas fotografias
assim carla lucas que como o bernardo
meu filho disse isso foi o que tirou a
fotografia portanto eu estava lá por
coisas que fomos todos para pó por
bandagens do arc são aquelas caras que
aguentam um o mastro e portanto somos
todos malucos malucos pelo mar e é isso
que é bom mas somos malucos aquilo que
há pouco foi dito nós sabemos onde é que
está o risco muito importante pra vocês
é preciso mar nós conhecermos os limites
onde podemos ir porque somos malucos mas
a gente que está cá há muito tempo para
podermos continuar a estar todos os dias
o que eu queria ser quando era pequenino
se calhar suplantar a vocês que querem
ser assim eu quero ser como cristiano
ronaldo
isto é muito envolvente que queria ser
quem é correspondido que queriam ser
quinteiro omc ciro é uma profissão muito
nobre muito importante
muitas coisas lá em sua casa foram
feitos por carpinteiros
olha só que comprar coisas pois é
difícil precisa ser mais com o
carpinteiro e vocês disse o físico boa
isto tem a ver com a envolvendo nós
estamos com o que os clubes acompanham e
apanhou na china há muitos anos e tinha
perto nove anos quando o homem foi à lua
que ser que ser astronauta isto era um
crachá que eu fui encontrar há uns anos
atrás que era o yang adicional do
programa era um programa pastoral altas
vocês têm que pensar uma coisa os sonhos
quando você começou a sonhar a dimensão
de um sonho é uma coisa que é entre
disponível é em tribunal é inimaginável
nós temos sim o que quisermos
agora temos é que pude aprender como é
que vamos concretizar os sonhos mas pra
que nós chegamos a esta fase de sonhar
concretizar fazer acontecer eu vou te
contar a história nesta pequena história
vamos contar o que esteve na génese como
é que eu fui ajudar a buscar este ponto
foram livros calhar vocês hoje em dia
quando tem uma dúvida
quando tem aquela idéia de que se calhar
muitos de vocês este ano que em nada os
porquês porque isto porque aquilo não é
eu também tinha e foram três livros que
tiveram dezenas de aprendizagem porque
em geral livros porque foi meu pai quem
ofereceu é um livro muito antigas que os
fósseis mil toneladas vossas das vossas
próprias em casa se calhar o vosso pai
está em mim eu tinha este livro é o
livro que muitas vezes eu ia lá filiar
porque com maré azul e azul porque meteu
a boca de um produto aquilar como cor
azul não é que eu tenha a ver com as
características de cuba luz existe na
atmosfera existe azul depois é elos -
absorvida por menos a sua vida pela água
a água é transparente a água tem o azul
porque é é por menos a sua vida e à
medida que vamos ganhando é o azul que
vai ser predominante vamos perdendo
outras cores você usa
para dominar e que o céu se une com o
mar enfim todas estas coisas que
chamavam não pode nem sempre ser
lembrados por que estar ligados porque
está sempre a perguntar por que isso que
aquilo que encontro mas eo ao cheiro
nesta fase do que o que é que você está
em vocês têm uma necessidade enorme de
saber como é que as coisas acontecem
se calhar hoje em dia você se agarram
aipa do garrano num tablet e volver
google it é uma expressão que está hoje
na vossa no nosso cotidiano
eu era vai ao livro vai licitar tudo
livrinho vocês hoje vão ao google no
equipe não quer que saia e descobre os
porquê das coisas
a segunda coisa que escalar quando fui
crescendo passando à fase dos porquês ev
n cidade fazer acontecer e vi um livro
pai com 500 páginas como o meu tio e
padrinho do véu quando eu passando à
fase dos porquês tinha que chegar à fase
de fazer acontecer
então eu dei meus livros muitas páginas
muito difícil ler que já oficiou os meus
filhos e que chama uma carta para garcia
a carta parecia não tem nada não tem
nada 500 páginas é um livrinho assim
anda sempre comigo e você quer ser uma
história engraçada e este livro foi
assim tornou padrinho que é fazer
acontecer tem uma história muito simples
que quando em cuba vive a guerra entre
estados unidos e espanhóis enviaram à
cidade fazer a ligação entre o
presidente dos estados unidos e o
general garcia ou alguém crise como é
que nós vamos chegar aos 9 a se entregar
esta missiva para é resolver o problema
e ovar em crise não está fácil
chamamos aqui o roma quer um indivíduo
entregamos de carta e eleva a carta a
garcia
se calhar a e foi por isso que gera um
livro quando meu pai me dizia eo meu
tipo de óleo fernando tem que fazer isso
é o que fazer porque eu porque não vai
abrir mão e ocupa tamandaré e os
correios onde ficam os raios une como é
que eu vou até os raios leva uma carta a
garcia é uma expressão que hoje em dia
eu utilizo no mundo empresarial levar
uma carta a garcia é fazer acontecer
é isso que em termos de é de mensagem eu
estava com as pessoas viessem depois de
dados porque se nós temos que fazer
acontecer
não é pois nós sonharmos nós temos que
começar a trabalhar para correções
aconteçam
o sonho se vocês ficarem sentados na
cadeira eles não vão acontecer os 38
anos para chegar à antártida foram
trabalhando foram foram foram idéias que
tiveram que ser sustentáveis preparadas
para ficar sentada
portanto temos que fazer o que acontecer
o ultrapassando a fase dos porquês e por
outro
já a minha idéia do do mar estava comigo
é e uma das coisas engraçadas em que eu
viajo bastante pois eu vou contar a
minha profissão
a primeira coisa que eu faço quando
chegam ao sítio é onde está o mar têm
impedido de tomar rapidamente retomar
eu quero os mil diz a diana que está o
mar e itamar trabalhe primeira coisa que
eu faço eu tenho que orientar ok uma
arma tapar-lhe planta que está ali e é
engraçado eu cheguei qualquer lado seja
montanha seja na bélgica onde eu vivi
muito tempo ficou marca star wars sua e
onde é que a maré bali em uma cidade e
eu ao ler este livro sobreviver no mar
cruel está uma família que tinha uma
paixão muito grande para o marco zero a
fazer vela no pacífico é ir por um
impacto com uma orca é a orca decidiu
brincar com o barco e afundou e tentou
estimar que afundou em 30 e 30 segundos
à volta disso um rumo muito grande só
vou um pequenino arco e esta família
sobreviveu
naquela naquele barquinho que tá ali as
pessoas sobreviveram maxwell 38 dias só
sobreviveram porque por respeitar o mar
conhecia o mar e ovo uma regra que foi
imposta pelo pai deus quer era liderança
a organização e os tinham se organizar
dentro do dentro do marco e depois é o
manteve durante todo este estilo dele
laurie uma força de viver tanto é muito
importante que vocês pensem que o mar
tem que aprender tem que aprender é
estar no mar há muitos riscos como os
disso
depois de pensar em todas estas coisas
obviamente há referências na nossa vida
que foi uma das referências como voa
olhar pomar forma diferente já que estou
obviamente que eu quando vi a história
do já custou vi o brincar com o fim de
brigar com o fim de fazer aquelas
imagens fantásticas cco que o miguel
mostrou mas precisaram de um show é
preciso trabalhar muito e ajudar o saque
uma mensagem muito importante que é nós
temos invadir as águas do mar
primeiro temos que aprender a respeitá
las e temos que transportassem semana
cgd desta 10 diz respeito por todo o
tipo de vida que existe no mar
nós dependemos dela é vida os pais que
vocês como comer tudo aquilo que passa à
nossa volta
vai do mar ou muitos vêm do mar
inclusive aquilo que não é produtos do
mar vem por transportes mário e nós
temos que respeitar
então o que é que eu sou final só isto
com 16 anos entrar na marinha portuguesa
sou comandante da marinha portuguesa e
se é esta aventura então lançar ao mar
por profissão por amor paixão é iniciei
minha carreira ganha oficial da marinha
portuguesa e tinha uma missão zinho que
era com todos estes ensinamentos que eu
tive
contudo estes sonhos de querer fazer
crer os do acre fazer a diferença que
marcar a diferença em relação à minha
passagem por esta vida e deixar algum
lugar para os meus filhos eu quis não é
através da marinha podia pessoas
proteger umar salvar vidas humanas no
mar
obviamente que imagens fantásticas do
pôr do sol no mar o mar e
a atração e uma força nós conseguimos
ter uma imagem quando estive em 2001
2002 é seguir ou setembro uma missão de
proteção da vida humana no no mundo
inteiro o sistema um ataque terrorista
não sabíamos o que era movimentado uma
força naval para proteger os interesses
de todos para podermos é ajudar o pai eo
país eo planeta é responder com ataques
é que fossem nocivos ao planeta e o mar
pra mim como eu diz não é só ir à praia
meus pés
o mar tem as dimensões todas partes lago
orgulho
vocês não imaginam a nossa costa é
beleza que é meter a cabeça debaixo
d'água deixar o rabo de fora e olhar e
ver os peixinhos desde a zona da costa é
ter a profundidade das loucas
há coisas fantásticas este é o mar dos
açores
o mergulho que eu fiz no mar dos açores
para chamar a atenção da importância de
preservarmos o mar
o lixo se tira do marques nós todos
aspiramos quando andava de barco quando
o miguel disse davi ataque driblou pela
janela fora
nós somos responsáveis por preservar o
mar mas tive a sorte e tenha sorte
também lá acima
aqui essa expressão que eu acho que é
fantástico e hoje vão ter uma pessoa que
vai falar sobre isto por esta porta
passou falcões mais frases do mundo e eu
sou responsável pela defesa aérea da
marinha portuguesa e então pra conhecer
melhor o que classe mas passa os nossos
fantásticos pilotos da força aérea
portuguesa eu fui voar com eles e então
e sou eu andar o ex a isso não era eu a
pintar lembra se eu sou o pingüim está a
minha alcunha quando entrei na escola
naval é o país
gosto de andar dentro da água mas gosto
de conhecer e gostar de ir lá acima
sentir o que é que as pessoas estão e
como é que as pessoas reagem num mundo é
tão exigente como é o mundo da aviação
mas enfim e agora vamos pedir um grande
apoio para aproximar os próximos slides
o mary lynn
o arco íris é tranquilidade estamos no
mar mas nós temos sentidos e temos um
gozo é a animação é como eu dizer tudo
aquilo que o marlos pousada está aqui
neste sentido
vocês sabiam jogar futebol a onda certa
vamos lá fazer onda agora a onda começar
aqui neste canto da maia valongo 23
embora isso mesmo esmero e sus sentidos
são sentidos que nós temos agora o o som
omar bravo quando marta bravo tudo na
trave
é difícil esgotamos que iremos buscá-lo
você tem que saber que limpar
ultrapassar os sentidos nós no mar vamos
em todos os serviços operados e como
vocês fizeram o que a onda que existiu
em portugal a maior onda do mundo foi
surfada na nossa costa no canhão da
nazaré é um é uma explicação é que um
fundo uma zona muito funda que é o
canhão da nazaré que se encontra ali na
zona da nazaré e por ver que a opinião
que vai em direção ao mar provoca que
haja uma conjugação do mar que vai do
norte com a aproximação do mar a terra e
as ondas são provocadas por que com a
aproximação da terra diminui a distância
o fundo do gol deu eu velocidade com que
ela se aproxima terra aonde é obrigado a
crescer para cima e tentei isso que faz
é gigante onda da nazaré que é o max
mara vai cá o senhor fala com mais 30
metros
nós temos tudo para o estado mara mas
temos que respeitar
temos que olhar pra eu com o maior
respeito maior conhecimento
se você perguntasse portugal como também
de portugal
tamanha que em portugal é este mapa que
está aqui que vocês conhecem
em portugal os açores ea madeira
o portugal é muito maior que isto espera
portugal há uns anos atrás
temos aqui a costa continental pois
temos aqui aquelas cores diferentes que
a zona é muito próxima do terra pois
temos uma zona mais alargada que se na
zona económica exclusiva que não podemos
pescar não podemos estar etc mas
portugal neste momento graças a um
investimento muito grande
nós temos quatro milhões de quilômetros
quadrados e porque temos quatro meses
porque lá os cuidados porque fomos lá
procurar ao fundo do mar
nós neste momento conhecemos desde a
superfície até ao fundo tanto sonnen
sonnen que com trabalho com muita
dedicação
os vossos sonhos podem se concretizar
agora tenho cuidado uma coisa sonhar é
com muita força
vocês podem ter um problema é que o
sonho de ser astronauta pode acontecer
tanto nunca se esqueçam e vejo que a
área dos 4 milhões de metros quadrados
km quadrados é tão grande como europa
sobre podemos aqui o mapa em cima deste
mas é o tamanho portugal tem no mundo
portanto convido os embarca em da
aventura que você escreva em sônia
trabalha em pane e ela acontece
nós nunca se esqueçam o sucesso só com
teste antes de trabalhar no dicionário
obrigado
ae